all right lots of news to cover this
morning so let's get to it this morning
President Trump is at the g20 summit in
Buenos Aires where he's still thinking
about robert muller in fact just moments
before taking the stage with Argentina's
president mr. Trump sent another tweet
attacking the special council's Russia
investigation his former lawyer Michael
Cohen revealed he is cooperating with
Muller after a surprise guilty plea
yesterday Cohen admitted he lied to
Congress out of loyalty to the president
and to be consistent with his political
messaging Cohn's plea deal is the
biggest development in Muller's
year-and-a-half long investigation yet
Muller has now secured guilty pleas from
five men closely connected to the
president or his campaign Paula Reid is
covering the Muller probe she has been
very busy Paula good morning good
morning sources tell CBS News President
Trump was told in advance about Cohen
preparing to enter a plea deal with
Robert Muller this may help explain why
the President appeared especially
agitated all week lashing out against
the investigation on a daily basis
president Trump reacted sharply to news
of Michael Cohen admitting he lied to
Congress what he's trying to do is get a
reduced sentence so he's lying about a
project in August of last year Cohen
told Congress a plan to build a Trump
Tower Moscow was under consideration
from September 2015 until the end of
January 2016 but on Thursday Cohen
revealed candidate Trump continued to
pursue the Moscow project until June of
2016 long after he had essentially
secured the Republican nomination
raising questions about the extent to
which the president's business empire
was entangled with his political
ambition a month later mr. Trump posed
this question wouldn't it be a great
thing if we could actually get along
with Russia wouldn't that be a good
thing but now it's not just political
mr. Cohen has cooperated on Thursday it
became personal Cohen Court documents
mentioned as late as June 2016 he
discussed the status of the Moscow
project with mr. Trump on more than
three occasions and briefed family
members Michael Cohen is why as the
investigation gets closer to the Trump
family the president
is defiant even if he was right it
doesn't matter because I was allowed to
do whatever I wanted during the campaign
I was running my business but the
pressure is building lying to Congress
is a very serious offense as he faces a
soon-to-be Democrat led House of
Representatives suspect that there are
more dealings that signal Thursday
there's more to come we need to look
into among other things incredible
allegations that the Russians may have
been laundering money for the Trump
Organization sources tell CBS News part
of the president's written answers to
Muller included a description of the
Trump Tower Moscow project that was in
line with Cohen's but the special
counsel did not ask about the timing of
those discussions so let's separate the
political ramifications from the legal
Paula would it have been illegal for
them candidate Trump's company to be
working on a business deal in another
country oh there's nothing illegal about
these preliminary discussions which begs
the question then why lie about them and
this falls into this larger pattern
we're seeing in this investigation
with so many Trump campaign associates
lying about their contacts with Russia
that were otherwise legally of Michael
Cohen you Michael Flynn Paul Manafort
Richard gates towards Papadopoulos and
former attorney general Jeff Sessions
and the special counsel is looking at
all of these contacts at a time when
Russia was trying to sabotage the u.s.
election and a lot of this goes beyond
just PR spin trying to distance yourself
from Russia these are people who are
lying to Congress or federal
investigators risking jail time to lie
about these contacts the big question
that's why one thing a lot of the media
a totally different thing to light of it
to Muller exactly in light of the press
you can lie to your friends you cannot
lie to the FBI oh thank you more to come
Thank You Paula